for someone trying to get into Greek
mythology it can be a very daunting
process learning who is the god of what
and who gave birth to whom can be a very
confusing time if you've ever looked at
a family tree of the Greek gods then
there's a good chance you are more
confused and before you began hopefully
after this video you'll have a better
understanding of the gods in Greek
mythology and their origins we can break
down the gods and goddesses in Greek
mythology into three generations the
primordial deities the Titans and the
Olympians the primordial deities being
the first generation were often more
symbolic of the creation of the world
rather than literal beings in the very
beginning there was nothing an empty
void first came chaos and from chaos
emerged Gaia Gaia symbolized the earth
and was considered the mother of all
beneath the earth was a primordial deity
Tartarus many compare he's domain to
Hades or the underworld
Tartarus was where the most ferocious
monsters and horrid criminals were
banished and on occasion even gods were
imprisoned in Tartarus from the chaos
came Erebus the darkness of a night that
would cover the earth when Erebus lay
with the night they gave birth to the
ether the heavenly light the early
sunrise to contrast the darkness from
the night we will also see such things
as fate doom sleep and even death
Gaia would give birth to Uranus the
mountains and pontus the primordial
deity of the sea Uranus represented the
sky in all its beauty and proved himself
to be equal to Gaia eventually becoming
her mate in some variations
it was eros the primordial deity of
shining love that blessed their union
but in other depictions eros was born
later the son of Aphrodite
together Gaia and Uranus produced the
twelve Titans along with three giant
Cyclops and three horrifying eckerton
Crees Uranus despised his children
particularly the Hecate encrease because
of how ugly he felt they were he hated
them so much that he pushed him back
into Gaia's womb and kept them there in
enormous pain Gaia fashioned a sickle
for her children to avenge her with but
the only child brave enough to do so was
Cronus the last born of the Titans
later that evening when Uranus lay
asleep Cronus ambushed his father he
took his father's genitals and severed
them with the sickle
the blood that began to pour from Uranus
created a race of giants nymphs and
Furies Cronus then threw the severed
genitals into the sea and from those
arose Aphrodite the goddess of love who
made her way to the shore Uranus now
mutilated left the earth forever but he
promised that Cronus and the other
Titans will be punished for their
actions with Uranus gone Cronus exiled
the Cyclops and hokotan Crees to
Tartarus
so his reign over the earth could be
established we haven't discussed the
Titans much thus far but this is where
their rule began there were two
generations of Titans the first 12 born
from Gaia are as follows Caius the Titan
of intelligence and foresight crius the
Titan of heavenly constellations Cronus
the Titan of time and the ages a pitous
the Titan of the mortal lifespan
Mnemosyne the Titan of memory and
remembrance
Oceanus the title of the sea phoebe the
tightness of radiance
rheya the tightness of fertility and
motherhood death ease the tightness of
fresh water via the tightness of shining
light and thermos the tightness of
divine law and order the most commonly
known tightens when the second
generation were Atlas the Titan of
endurance aoe's the tightness of dawn
Epimetheus and his brother Prometheus
the Titans of afterthought and
forethought Helios the Titan of the Sun
and Leto the tightness of motherhood
having now established himself as the
head of the Titans Cronus Turkey's
sister Rhea as his mate and together
they had many offspring Cronus was
terrified of a prophecy that Uranus and
Gaia had foretold that Cronus would be
replaced by one of his sons ray gave
birth to the first six Olympians Hestia
the goddess of the family hearth and
sacrificial flame Demeter the goddess of
agriculture Hera the goddess of marriage
and family Hades the god of the
underworld Poseidon the god of the sea
and zeus the god of the sky upon seeing
his children Cronus swallowed them whole
in an attempt to stop the prophecy
coming true Raya was distraught that her
children were devoured and decided that
she would hide her last born Zeus she
gave Cronus a stone disguised as ooze to
swallow instead Zeus was then sent to
Crete where he would be raised by the
nymphs until he was strong enough to
rebel against his father as the time
passed
Cronus grew old and weak and Zeus only
grew stronger to aid him in his fight
against his father Zeus was given a
potion and when Cronus drank this potion
he vomited up all of Zeus's brothers and
sisters who were unharmed
together with the other Olympians they
were able to overpower Cronus and
banished him to Tartarus
despite their victory the wall of the
Titans had only just begun as all except
Prometheus and Oceanus rebelled against
the Olympians for ten years the war
raged on with neither side able to
secure decisive victory that was until
the sous travelled to Tartarus and
released the Cyclops and hacked
inquiries the three Cyclops is rewarded
Zeus with the power of thunder and
lightning and the heck tonker is pelted
the Titans with large boulders with the
additional help the Titans were
eventually defeated and Zeus imprison
them in Tartarus the Titan Atlas was
condemned to stand forever with the
weight of the earth and heavens on his
shoulders having watched a downfall of
their children Gaia and Uranus gave
birth to one last monster - be father of
all monsters the gods terrified began to
flee but Zeus would not let his kingdom
crumble hurling lightning at the Beast
over and over until it was defeated
there was one final attempt to overthrow
the Olympians the Giants that were made
from Uranus's blood were unhappy with
the way they were treated and began to
lay siege to Olympus scaling the
mountain to reach the gods with the aid
of Heracles they were able to subdue and
kill the Giants with all their enemies
defeated or banished
no one could dispute the rule of the
Olympians and Zeus took his place on the
throne there are many variations of the
gods creation in Greek mythology and
some are most definitely more crude than
others this version does have some
recurring features such as the mothers
aid in their children Indy throne in
their husbands with Uranus and Cronus
both being defeated by their children
almost as if history was doomed to
repeat itself
the desire of power and dominance is
something that is shared through all
three generations of the gods and
goddesses and most likely reflects
mankind's desire for power another
important thing to note is when
referring to most of the primordial
deities and even some of the Titans they
are more of a personification or a
symbol of concepts rather than physical
beings the last generation the Olympians
have more defined appearances and traits
that we can easily identify with from
Zeus's lightning to Poseidon's trident I
can only hope that this video has been
informative for you guys and if it has
then please consider given an alike feel
free to share any other variations
regarding the creations of the gods and
goddesses in the comments below I'll be
covering all the gods and goddesses in
their own individual videos but if
there's something you'd like to see then
please let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained